[Music]
foreign
spending on Health Care in the United
States is 19 of GDP it is the largest
industry by far studying Healthcare
Management and being involved in trying
to improve the delivery of Health Care
in the U.S is both a noble and a
practical Endeavor and then on the
policy side there's always a lot of push
and pull and you know increasingly
arguments of misinformation or
disinformation and things like that so
it's really important to have
well-trained rigorous thinkers in the
world of Health policy if we're going to
improve the health for all across the
United States and the world
[Music]
so she has a legislative fellows program
where she
trains students and they're going and
providing legislative research support
to the state of Connecticut's
legislature that linking of research to
the teaching and then giving the
students an opportunity to take that
research sort of expertise that they're
developing and deploy it to affect
policy is a real strength of the
department
foreign
and Jacob Wallace who are working on
issues around Medicaid policy and in
particular thinking about how to make
Medicaid more efficient from an
administrative perspective and to help
people who are in the Medicaid Program
make decisions around being enrolled
perhaps you know choosing between plans
and states that allow for you know some
privatization of Medicaid and choice and
a lot of work around how to make that
Medicaid system better using some
economic techniques Zach Cooper's work
he's been working a long time on really
you know high level problematic Health
policy issues around the delivery of
hospital care billing for hospital care
and the relationship between that and
insurance and you know most recently his
work has led to changes in how we think
about balance billing and so Zach did a
lot of work showing the negative impacts
of of these balanced billing practices
which ultimately led to Federal
legislation to change that and then we
have other faculty who are working in
the areas of mental health and substance
abuse policy they're thinking about the
delivery of health care services for
those with mental health whether they
can be delivered more efficiently and
also thinking about those areas of
mental health care services that perhaps
aren't efficient and and are consuming
resources that could be deployed
elsewhere in areas that would be more
effective we have two faculty members in
particular Jamie Tam and Abigail
Friedman who are still thinking very
hard about the problem of tobacco and
its consumption and the issues around
that particularly as it relates to
children and things like electronic
cigarettes we have Jason Schwartz who's
been working hard on thinking about
things like the groups that make
decisions around vaccines and whether to
be approved and this has been a serious
question and people hesitate actually to
get the vaccine still because it hasn't
gone through the traditional FDA
approval process the way vaccines
historically did and he's done a lot of
work along with one of our senior
colleagues David Paul teal in thinking
about policy modeling around how people
respond these different bits of
information that come out about coveted
vaccines and other covid prevention
measures when the pandemic first started
they were integral to the state of
Connecticut Yale University and some of
what they put out was a model used
around the country by other universities
and other states for covid mitigation
measures so if we're talking about real
world impact we have faculty that are
doing work that's changing lives day by
day
[Music]